[Music]
Potterheads can't wait to see the second
fantastic beasts movie in a series of
five and this is why they came up with
some really interesting theories JK
Rowling even confirmed that one of them
was true make sure you watch this video
until the end to know which character
could be one of Voldemort's only friends
if you love the Harry Potter universe as
much as we do don't forget to subscribe
and please give this video a big thumbs
up today we're showing you five theories
about fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald that will blow your mind
Ariana Dumbledore wasn't obscurus in
fantastic beasts and where to find them
we met [ __ ] spare Bo a young wizard
who was adopted by a mother who hated
magic he turned out to be a destructive
obscure EO who transformed into an
obscurus it is described as a
manifestation of the repressed energy of
a magical child that manifests itself as
a separate identity we learned a lot
about this in the first fantastic beasts
movie and many fans think that had
finally explained what happened to
Ariana
Dumbledore her sister passed away during
a duel between Albus and Grindelwald we
never knew what she had but we knew that
she was attacked by three muggles when
they saw her doing magic when she was
six years old
Aberforth said that it destroyed her and
she was never right again she wouldn't
use magic but she couldn't get rid of it
her brother described a force that
exploded out of her when she couldn't
control it she became so powerful that
she even accidentally killed her mother
and this is why many fans think that she
was in obscurest Grindelwald probably
tried to use this power just like he did
with credence and this would explain why
he and Dumbledore got into a fight that
ruined their friendship forever as it
was revealed that credence would be a
part of fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald we hope that young Albus
will know what to do to help him just
like he wanted to help his sister
Nicholas Flamel will be back as we knew
that the second fantastic beasts movie
was going to be set in Paris some fans
started thinking that we were going to
see a famous French character and it was
confirmed on Pottermore that we would
finally get the chance to see Nicolas
Flamel and fantastic
the crimes of Brenda wall the only thing
we know is that he's going to be played
by brawn test order out this is why fans
started thinking about what is going to
happen with him in Harry Potter and the
Philosopher's Stone he was known for
making the Philosopher's Stone that made
him immortal along with his wife there
now if you remember what was written on
Albus Dumbledore's chocolate frog card
you also know that he was known for his
work on alchemy with his partner
Nicholas Flamel
however ethnic Lewis was born in the
14th century he already created the
Philosopher's Stone to still be alive in
the 20th century which means that he
worked on something else with Dumbledore
fans think that if Brenda Wald was
looking for the Deathly Hallows just
like Voldemort will in the future the
two men might also be looking for the
Philosopher's Stone other people think
that his Flamel attended Bob at an
academy of magic
Dumbledore went to Hogwarts and
Grindelwald was expelled from durmstrang
these three men will represent the
Triwizard Tournament no matter what
happens and even if he's not important
in the story
we'll be happy to finally put a face on
this name Grindelwald is actually a seer
while watching the first fantastic
beasts and where to find them movie fans
notice many signs that could prove that
Grindelwald is even more powerful than
what we might think after all Lew Kooza
was investigating reports of a
mysterious force that destroyed
everything but Gellert pretending to be
Percival graves was the only one who
knew that it was associated with
credence he even made it clear that he
knew about that because he had some sort
of vision even though he was wrong when
thought that one of his little sisters
was the obscure you we understand that
he would have been misled by the fact
that he thought that these kids usually
don't grow up to teenagers he did know
that Creedence had something to do with
this but just couldn't believe that it
was him it led many people to think that
Grindelwald was actually a seer just
like professor Trelawney it means that
he has the ability to see prophecies
through his inner eye which explains why
he had visions and JK Rowling even
confirmed this theory on Twitter when a
fan asked her about this it can't be
just a little detail and we bet that
he's going to have even more visions
which will make him more powerful than
ever
what will he see next we'll have to wait
for the next fantastic beasts movie to
know more about this Jewish characters
will be involved in world war ii in the
fantastic beasts series we will get the
chance to learn more about the global
Wizarding war which ended in 1945 when
Dumbledore defeated Grindelwald it means
that wizards will fight in Europe for
world
two will take place in the muggle world
JK Rowling even said in 2005 when
talking about Hold'em org that it amused
her to make allusions to things that
were happening in the muggle world this
is why while there's a global muggle war
going on there is going to be a global
Wizarding war going on and the two will
feed each other we know that our
favorite fantastic these characters are
probably going to take part in the
Wizarding war but what about Jacob
Kowalski
the only muggle in the story his name is
really popular in Poland which means
that people might think that he's Jewish
and as he travels to Europe you might
even become one of the victims of the
Nazis it's also possible that the
Goldstein sisters are Jewish too after
all they are distant relatives of
Anthony Goldstein a young wizard who
joined Dumbledore's Army at Hogwarts he
is also known to be Jewish which means
that Tina and Queenie could be Jewish
too this will probably have an impact
during World War two in the fantastic B
series but we think that we're going to
wait for a couple of movies to see it
the maledictis is a snake in November
2016 warner brothers revealed who was
going to be part of the cast of
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald we're going to meet a couple
of new characters but the most
intriguing one was probably the unnamed
character played by claudia kim the only
thing we know about her is that she's a
maledictis the carrier of a blood curse
that Destin's her ultimately to
transform into a beast
this is what makes her the main
attraction at a magical circus that
we're going to see in the second movie
and based on the drawing of the circus
and her snake-like outfit many fans
think that she is going to be the
enchanted snake girl
moreover Iseult ser the founder of ill
horny was one of the descendents of
Salazar Slytherin and also the niece of
formless gone she met a snake who told
her that until he is part of her family
her family is doomed there could be a
length of the maledictis means that if
the new character turns into a snake she
could actually be the heir of Slytherin
that could be the reason why Warner
Brothers didn't want to tell us her name
and Potterheads who go even further
think that we've already met her and she
would turn out to be Nagini better known
as Voldemort's female snake after all
the Dark Lord wouldn't choose a snake
like any other and he would like one of
slytherins descendants by his side so
which theory is your favorite don't be
shy to tell us what you know about that
in the comment section down below we
love to hear what you think and that's
it for five theories about fantastic
beasts the crimes of Grindelwald that
will blow your mind for more stories
like this make sure you watch 10
disturbing real stories behind Disney
fairy tales thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]